whether it's on purpose or not this is  owning the news cycle and that means  Democrats are never going to get a a  minute of of time to talk you're right  so they've got no stars that Beto and  Abrams are their stars and they just  keep losing they're famous for losing  Beto's now lost what he heard three in  less than four years  in less than four years I want somebody  I was going to do it but I didn't have  time I want somebody to come out with a  meme that shows little African kids  wearing Beto shirts you know from after  the election and I want them to see like  these kids growing they've got a kid  that's Beto for Senate Beto for  president Beto for uh governor and just  they just keep growing in these shirts  uh and then you have a meme where  there's an outlet store called discount  clothing and it's all about no shirts  all the different kinds of beta  percentage for governor and I hope he  runs again because that's an easy  feeling